hi i'm mark i'm a bit of an [ __ ]
and you may remember in the end of my i
know you're all filling in the blanks of
why but let me explain before you fill
in the gaps
uh but you remember how i said at the
end of my i'm back from the hospital
video that i
was going to show you guys about how i'm
an [ __ ] well today's that day
and actually the day was two weeks ago
because
i posted an among us video about two
weeks back
uh real fun organized by the game grumps
and ross and had proximity chat and a
whole bunch of other people and it was
really cool and i liked it a lot
and also i wasn't supposed to do that at
all
there was an important note in the
invitation that said
very specifically hey don't post this
video before the agreed upon date
if you do we won't be able to do this
big cross-promotional thing so that
people can see each other's channels
and you know it can drive a lot of
people to see new content across youtube
and it'd be really cool and kind of
cooperative and it'd be really fun
i didn't do any of that because i didn't
read it so i'm an
[ __ ]
they had to make a follow-up message
that was just like hey guys
please don't post your videos before
it's time
so i'm an [ __ ] but we can make this
right we can fix it
you can fix it for me but don't worry
i'll get my just desserts just follow me
through this i need a favor
please just follow through on this and
everything will be okay
in the description there is a link to
everyone else's video
go to one of them and just leave a like
and then type in a comment like
hey this is such a great video i love
this video
what a fantastic video thank you for
this video hit enter
come back here go to the next one and
then leave a like type
wow what a cool video i can't believe
this video exists it's incredible in
every way i've never seen a better video
enter and then come back here and do
that for every single one of the videos
in the description
and that way you can send a lot of love
to those
other people that were a part of it that
i didn't
send the love to by promoting early
and then when you get all those videos
done okay follow me when you get all
those videos done
come back here and dislike this video
okay
just to trust me on this one just come
back here
dislike this video go to those videos
watch them all
come back here dislike this video leave
a comment that's like
boo what a bad youtuber this video is
terrible i can't believe i watched this
video and then i guess you can watch
this video if you want but i would
highly encourage you guys to watch the
other people's perspectives
because there was a lot of cool people
in that session and i'm glad to have
been invited to it
and i know that i'll never be invited
again so this is my last hurrah
so thank you guys for doing me this
favor
all right uh now i'm gonna play the
video now which i don't know if you'll
watch
hey there it is i'm not an imposter just
fyi
you said it before it came up so i don't
know if we can buy that
oh what's up oh god my screen was full
all right uploading stuff
oh god damn it so close we walked up on
the body and we found
dodger there
wait what i couldn't even what i
couldn't even
ross did are you saying you walked up on
the body with me no no you from the
other direction you came from the other
direction i walked up and found dodger
on it what
no no we you were both together i would
like to be particularly clear that the
lights are off so i didn't even see the
body i just have to hit report i
also did not know i walked up and i saw
the report button flicker and dodger was
standing next to it
i saw dodger also leaving and rock like
i saw the report flash so i i
would love to accuse dodger but she has
immunity
we had a [ __ ] deal she literally
hasn't even
do it again look i didn't see anything i
just saw a report and i know jayden was
behind me
yeah i'm pretty sus of ross and jaden
right now because they're working
together pretty hard
yeah no it wasn't jaden look at those
early votes
for 2013. and i'm also going to say i
have medpay if anyone would like to
watch me get scanned that would be
good oh sick i don't know if i have
medpay i should check that out
unbelievable
it didn't work anyway he's fine he's
fine
all right we're good everybody's fine
we're all still friends except for sean
and we still gotta fix these [ __ ]
lights i'm gonna fix
the lights i'm going to fix them
i'm fixing the lights this door is
closed
well this is odd these doors
really weird
yeah no i got this one next to it
[Laughter]
what are you uploading i'm uploading
stuff from my tablet to the world wide
web
no uh i have a question for
aaron and and dan so
you guys were in office right yeah what
did you do in there
i looked at each other and said please
don't kill me and
then i said please don't kill me yeah
i said i wouldn't do that in front of my
children and then i walked away from dan
yeah i did hear that where you would be
the little
purple the like the conference area the
entire time
yes i had to do the water jug thing
that's right in the conference room and
then i had to do the whatever
was on the wall in like the hallway on
the left someone killed right in the
other room while you guys were talking
oh jesus well mark
knows
i was in specimen so a little bit far
from me uh
i mean you could have killed and then
ran into specimens true
you could have not been in specimen but
i was on like the far right like side
still coming down mark where were you i
was with aaron
but i do think that is suspicious
because if both of them were there and
you were there that's
i was there that's three other people
that couldn't have been there raw city
was in
a specimen so that leaves two possible
people besides you that could have been
in there i don't think mark did you say
you were in there as well
no i was i was in the upload area with
aaron so i think that aaron's clear
and then dan i i just look at him how
could you but i think it's a self-report
for no evidence at all and i have
nothing to say about it i don't know
i could be no i'm i'm a little suss of
mark because wait aaron how come you
didn't
mention mark being with you oh he did
yeah oh he did yeah i think it's ross
oh wait i've been wait sorry i might not
be hearing aaron i need to refresh
it's definitely not aaron that's all i'm
saying hell yeah i would never do that
in front of my kids
uh i'm gonna go vote and rush mark
oh [ __ ] okay how dare you
get out all right good luck guys
hell yeah we did it we did it you're
gonna get that uploaded
just fixing lights
hey oh hey how you doing hey man
okay all right who's who's doing who's
doing that
okay good collab i'm gonna go to laughs
yeah well me too yeah
weird huh maybe i'm not going to laugh
yeah weird okay weird i think she's a
mutterer
yeah i think so too i definitely think
so with my back all exposed
my back's so exposed you have body scan
by any chance
no i don't unfortunately do you can i
tell
i'm watching and by myself that looks
good that looks good that checks out
thank you here uh-oh
oh god all right i trust you oh no
alana's on the end no
yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm just waiting because
i stopped and i'd like a buddy
i'll be your buddy please don't get me
wrong
aaron could die my tasks are all done so
if i'm not at anything because i'm all
done
huh who's there mark all right jaden's
here okay i'm here
where's alana
[ __ ] marco oh [ __ ] i'm gonna take vitals
i think it's jade i think it's jaden i
think she was counting out loud that was
really i don't know man
it was it was making me feel weird it
was really weird we wanna wait where'd
alana
wait i'll go back i'll go check
you alive you alive in here hello
to come over here okay no no no uh dan i
don't know if you're good
don't worry i'll watch you he kills
either of us
who are you dark okay goddamn lights
aaron come with me
we're going let's go again follow me
follow my voice
just don't break stride okay if any we
just gotta talk constantly because if
our voice is cut out we know we're dead
yep yep we're good
yeah yeah we're good we're good we're
talking talking talking talking
so talking dude pressing buttons all
right all right we're good
we're good there's a lot of people
together everything's good
oh my god who did
it it was hacker who did it was a hacker
right in
i've been potting with all of these
people i've potted with alana mark and i
don't know who
is
[Laughter]
aaron who did you vote for i voted for
hacker it's clearly hacker
is it are we sure your character model
listen it's not
clearly hacker yes it is your character
model moved all the jittery ones got
murdered
sometimes you know how like sometimes
there's like bugs
in the system bugs bug snack get it
oh gotcha that's a good rebuttal anyway
you [ __ ] mudded someone right in
front of you
i was scared of jaden the whole time
[Music]
wait
i cannot say for certain but
i went oh hey there's dan and then i
walk around the corner and there's a
dead body there
and so i can't say absolutely for
certain
that one plus one equals that i can't i
didn't see it happen but
really close dan what's your math in the
situation
oh dan where were you uh where were you
stan
press control where are you control arms
i still can't hear dan so i'm assuming
he admitted to doing it
okay yeah
all right delayed like three times yeah
you've done it yeah i've done it too i
can't hear him for some reason
well he's dead now all right well i hear
i hear him like all muffled in the
distance
all right oh yeah i got a card swipe i
got card swipes nailed it
all the voices faded away
the wheels in here turn really slow
mark's coming in no i
guys okay
this looks bad me reporting two in a row
i get it
it's a bit suspicious i look
i didn't see anybody this time so
could have been anyone it was right
outside it's like where lights fix is
across the fence from that
where like a little electrical coil is
thing between that and storage
i don't know though i will i think i
believe mark because mark gets
louder when he's guilty and he accuses
dad he wouldn't just out down
immediately i wouldn't do that guys i
wouldn't yeah i don't think he would do
that
guys i wouldn't if rossi
and sean talking to each other and they
said uh are you going to kill me and
jane said unfortunately i cannot i was
on cams that entire time
okay well i was with sean and i was with
susie
and i saw mark go in and then go up i
think and that's where he found body so
i think and he he came in from bottom
it's not it's it's
literally not me i did not leave cams
that entire round
pay attention to the red lights you
would know that they were on the entire
time
i was only with aaron out and doing my
tasks
i don't even know the areas that you're
talking about
if you're such a good crewmate named
every task oh no
dumb sticker points to dumb sticker
i kind of want to shoot ross out of a
cannon i think it's a bad idea i would
be known cams this entire time
okay where are you
because i'm trying to catch people
that's how cams work did you catch
anyone though well we can't wait no
because no one's killed
him we should just get him out of here
because he's useless
okay i'm gonna say it's susie because
she's
oh he's pinning it on someone else i
think ross might be
it i am not okay well good luck guys
because i am 100
not and you know the round is not going
to end i believe in you i die and the
round keeps going
it's either susie or aaron
aaron well i gotta like rehab my image
everyone always thinks it's me
all right good luck guys yeah i don't
know
some pr among us pr yeah
oh yes yeah oh no uh oh no
oh i gotta finish o2 all right hi i hope
i don't find another body
i hope i'm not the other body
oh geez who's there
where were you i was on cams i never
looked at the camera
no i didn't i've never seen cams before
i never knew about them
so i was looking at them wait how do you
look at it just hit the button i think i
don't know if we can all
right yeah okay oh there's
i see sean well
wow i didn't know we could watch each
other oh there goes sean
wait they're together what if they're
what if
wait then the only one missing is aaron
right i think he's dead i heard him
scream
scream he's somewhere i guess we can
like go
okay wait where were they yeah they're
they're looking for us right now they're
looking for us they're gonna double kill
us
well actually unless dan might but
didn't dan admit
anna's out dan got killed admitted that
he was one
he made it so it's either okay so it's
either shawn or
jaden so we just gotta find one of the
bodies stick together fix the lights
first right
the lights are not are the lights broken
no they're not they're fine
are they okay yeah they're fine i mean
for me i think they were they were
in here maybe were they here okay
yeah they're they were around here on
the cams hello
did you find him hey we found a body
where was it
uh it was it was mark and us and we were
uh
i don't know where the placement is but
it's the very bottom middle
it's like out of the office and bottom
okay yeah so
this this is awfully suspicious
dodger and i were all together and we
didn't kill anybody
i think you know who it is i think i
know this is why people always think
you're the killer
and it's not like it was me
it was dodger what what but i was with
them
yeah i don't think it was dodger she
killed earlier i went to the vitals
we both did the same task together i
don't know if she would live she ran up
from that area earlier
what area the bottom area where the body
is and then i went in to check vitals
saw aaron was dead went looking for his
body
so suspicious of sean
all she had to do was meet up with you
guys after she killed and just sit there
no
it's impossible no other kills happened
wait a minute yeah wait you and jaden
were together wait
no you're right you and jayden were
together there's only one other imposter
if you two were together one of you
could have killed the other one
therefore he must
susie no no
what oh no i don't think it's dodger
guys oh god this is the most confusing
round
i think wait oh what if it is
people have such mismatching ways of
talking
oh my god my brain was melting at the
end there just like
i just want to point out again i didn't
do it that time okay i'm not an
impossible
it's a witch vibes you know you believe
me
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
happened how did this happen so fast i
came out of keys saw a report button
i will say that i was not there because
i did the uh cutscene skip to run down
so i was nowhere even near you guys the
one time we have keys ross and you don't
do them i know
i scare because you don't get to see it
if you skip so i don't know until
like after the fact i'm gonna say i
think didn't do it because
i was one of the first to leave keys and
run away and hacker was in my line of
sight kind of just behind me
i could be wrong no you are completely
correct
good yes excellent i don't even know who
was in the pile i just finished my keys
and saw body
oh man for some reason i'm obsessed with
mark no
i was fiddling with the key i believe it
worked i was fiddling
because the lights got flicked so fast
and he's a sabotage boy
that's all i'm gonna say uh well i
couldn't have done the kill because i
wasn't even near you guys yeah but you
could have done the lights
yeah i mean anyone could have done the
lights alana yeah but you did it real
fast i mean if
you did do the cutscene skip then it
couldn't have been him if he's not in
the area
no i don't think he did this not for
this one no i'm not
i think we can't figure it out i think
we gotta skip no matter what yeah i
skipped
dan oh [ __ ] is there anyone else i'm
still getting echo now i hear him
i'm hey next guy goodbye nobody
all right all right i'm running my tiny
lights
legs are fast i'm going i feel like
you're sort of tall sean i don't feel
like you're that
tiny what are you like six something
seven yeah he no he's six eleven he's
he's tall yeah that sounds right yeah
mark six twelve yeah you know just a
little bit taller but you know it's all
it's all good
he's counting really right i think she's
gone yeah she's she's gone
okay
oh hi hi i'm just walking in here me and
my dog
i've got a water wheel this time i heard
that
water wheel right what doing these
canisters
what oh you dragged them down and then
they filled them
you pulled them out i thought i did it
wrong they just exploded off to the
right
we're all dead you [ __ ] up our oxygen
well you know
hey what's up please don't kill me in
front of my children they would never
they would never get over it i would
hear it too i'm worried about giving my
location away
that would be i walked past
um uh ross and i heard him say the
phrase
those idiots those idiots that's
definitely a ross phrase
oh god the lights again i'm going oh
oh no oh no okay so what what what info
do we got
so uh jack and i were together
and then i stepped outside to go up
north
and saw the body
[Laughter]
sick i mean i i did my download i'm on
my way to upload i don't know what else
to tell you
so i have some good news dan and i
are now accountabilo buddies
yeah i'm very impressed we scanned
together we scanned respectively
and dan what did you do to do this scan
what did what did
ross walk you through this process tell
us the process okay
ross said stand on the scanner and does
it say waiting for ross
and it did and he was like cool then we
can
uh then we're official account of bill
buddies i trust him
and i've never trusted ross okay okay
that was way too specific
because it's pretty damning yeah if ross
said a thing
if ross was just like just say with the
word med scan buddies you wouldn't know
that so that's great
okay i also did o2 with mark so i
he didn't know what he was doing on it
so i'm pretty sure he's clear
yeah the bottles go to the right which
doesn't seem like they're done yeah he
thought he killed us all
well i thought it just meant that like
you did it wrong and all the air left
and i was like ah well [ __ ] and then i
did it again and then it was done
yeah that's my story i did see hacker
go up and then she she also has been
very quiet which makes me very
oh i'm just kidding i can tell you what
happened
i was in the communications mark was
there i heard somebody say something
about ross i'm like oh that's funny
i'm gonna go see if he's on cameras he
wasn't on camera the lights turned off i
went to lights then the body was
reported
that's true there was there was some
general making fun of ross
sorry ross it's okay unless it's ross
and dan
no because they're vouching for each
other
okay i feel like it's very specific what
dance i count the bell buddy and i don't
appreciate that
also you know what dan wouldn't know
what an accountability system is
[Music]
that's true because sean i didn't click
anything i just opened it and i was
checking to see if switches flipped
automatically so
no no you're you're clear you're good
okay good i gotta do my key i'm doing my
keys you didn't read your keys yet
i didn't get it at first it was a
kerfuffle don't kill me do not kill me i
swear if you kill me
i scream real loud everyone will know
okay everyone will know and it's not me
it's oh my god you're still following me
it's on the channel i just saw you on
vent i just saw sean van i just saw sean
van impe oh
and what are you doing around the corner
like that i
saw sean vance i saw sean fan
sean killed killed dan and then and then
went in the van out of communications
oh god oh okay i just wanted to
free one okay
i mean it's ross
drew i'm voting right got him guys oh my
god
let's all vote for ross aaron vote ross
what why if you love me and irish people
you vote ross
who's everybody i only want to be i only
want to be popular amongst the people
who
i saw him do it aaron no it's
sean listen to the sound of his voice
god damn it
aaron vote ross yeah don't be a fool
we all voted for sean actually dan
confirmed me
damn right
[Laughter]
oh no there's still a killer amongst us
that's a problem
[Music]
hmm this is strange
okay wait someone no
come with me to the left one because
that's the murder one
oh never mind is there anybody dead over
here anybody dead
oh okay no i got a task in laboratory
okay i'm going i'm going with you i'm
going i'm sticking with you i have no
more tasks
i have one more test i'm going
hello hello i'm done with my tasks
oh no uh if anyone's in here it's either
aaron or hacker
okay oh god i don't see where did they
go
i don't know i just got out of specimen
room i looked up here to check if anyone
was dead
hi hi no one is dead do you guys want to
go to vitals
back
it is
let's go to the left one and it will be
okay
of the wrong person it is not me there's
a dead body around here somewhere
where is it okay hold on i need you i'm
going through this said pink was alive
he is alive i need somebody to account
for me it is not
okay all right fine i'm willing to vouch
for you i'm willing but if you betray me
if you betray me i mean
mark yeah what's up i think it's i think
it's uh
wait where has dodger being this entire
time that's a good point
aaron is dead aaron's dead and has been
for a long time
but we left for a long time we left
hacker with aaron at a point didn't we
okay no you want to know what happened i
was going to specimen to finish my last
task
and aaron was in the decontamination
thing he's like oh i don't trust you and
he ran away and so he went i was gonna i
was literally gonna say i saw aaron
at some point and he was like i think
it's axer and i'm scared
literally
i i literally looked in her eyes at the
end there
and i said i'm gonna trust you there was
a perfect opportunity to murder me we
were isolated
one was around it could have happened i
think i wasn't
in the reactor area at all that's just
yeah i don't i don't see dogs i don't
know how the reactor stuff works i was
trying to get doors open
that would explain why it was so safe at
the reactor every time
i think it's i'm voting hack i'm not i'm
voting i'm voting doctor
i totally forgot doctor was even alive
everyone yeah
i was actually surprised i'm real you've
just been very quiet
and i haven't seen i haven't seen you at
all oh
[Laughter]
it's either if it's not this it's hacker
it's not me
hey oh hell yeah i was getting scared
yeah no i i trusted you right at the air
and it paid off
uh aaron texted me and said move the mic
away from your face you heavy breathing
bastard
then i looked up jack killed me and then
immediately said i can't believe ross
just killed dan
i got rid of the hat so i no longer have
the evil vibe
of the bat that's good that's something
an imposter would do
by the way i'm not the imposter uh
number one crewmate any speed record
coming up yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god what i'm sorry
hello please don't kill me please i
won't kill you
i won't do it please don't kill me all
right
hi oh you changed your hat yeah i didn't
want to be suspected as much this time
so
i suspect you more now
do you have scan i have scan i have
choice for you
they're not chores drag my shape oh [ __ ]
god damn it
every time i'm [ __ ] uploading to the
world wide web i was gonna say
if i've ever been so sure of anything i
was sure that it was not ross
because nobody had died yet and nothing
had been sabotaged
it it really pains me to say this
but i crossed paths
with mortimer oh sweet no no
[Laughter]
i have chores to do again and they're
not yours
we all know this i i will say susie had
a really easy chance to kill me and she
didn't take it
so that's true yeah you're alone with
ross on vitals and now ross is dead
but i will say suzy if you promise to
not
kill anyone i will not vote for you
that's true susie had a good opportunity
looked me right in the eyes and that
always works
thank you you're right in the devil
wings
look at that oh we all skip see this is
great yeah sue's immunity we call it
yeah i'm gonna find out who did this
[Laughter]
yeah
it's time to do tests yes time to do
tasks
i love doing tasks that sounds like
someone who loves doing path
and that's me good task work
there buddy all right all done here
i am having a jovial merriment of task
good
good quick shower after a hard day's
work
very good yeah very good pass with new
england yeah oh you have this one too
interesting that anomaly well got a scan
it's very very right
i would appreciate if you didn't watch
as i got scanned it's a little intrusive
it's okay well it's over now oh hi
hi all right bye bye
who said i'mma kill ya who just said
that
who just went i'm gonna kill you hmm
yeah it's stupid you have to wait like a
set number of seconds
hell yeah i finished all my tasks so
let's go
i'm finished with all my tasks titles
maybe sure you have mock
i have yes
[Music]
oh no one's dead real stab-able back you
got there
that's not bad i'm gonna be just fine i
think yeah i'm gonna escort you hakko
thank you
[Music]
hello oh [ __ ] you're not you're not a
murderer are you
no no i'm trying to watch someone else
get murdered good me too
so you're into that kind of stuff yeah
mark
this isn't about my weird quirks this is
about trying to solve a mystery
yeah yeah well i mean the quirks are the
perks you know what i'm talking about
who do you think it is man this would be
a perfect time for me to go me and then
stab you in the back but i
i'm not i would totally do that right
now if i was
i know i know it would it would have
been awesome it would have been so
cinematic that would have been so
cool oh [ __ ] hi hacker hi i heard
conversation about people stabbing each
other in the back and i really wish
someone would do that right now
yeah yeah nobody's dying well i'm just
going to excuse me that's my cue to
leave
there's gonna be boys you know santa's
ran away where's ross where's ross
there's a lot of people
nervous right now for a long time
he's dead he's touched but i'm a [ __ ]
i'm just gonna stand here so you guys
can see me look okay yeah let's just all
meanwhile nobody's dying
what is that neatly in this group
[Music]
uh-huh okay
nothing has happened i just thought that
i would call you all here today
to ask if everyone's up to date on their
tasks yeah
i've done all of mine i'm older i'm
trying to do mine but i'm too busy
proving my innocence
[Laughter]
did not have a use button
i think it was just a bug okay it
happened no one's like everyone's hats
keep disappearing
so what i'm gonna do i love you you know
i love you too
i mean yeah it could have been the
sample thing that things complicated who
knows what
how that right yeah right yeah it's a
classic skip one night
it didn't even work why did you all have
to make me
live this life and stare at my wife down
with this accusation
that's fine we could just win on tasks
oh i lived you're like who has talked
in the room does anyone want an escort
no i'm all done
i've done all of mine i'm
okay well if everyone's gonna follow me
then i'm just gonna i think we should
all just stay here
it's cold
who has toss left it doesn't make sense
yes who has remaining tasks
if you press q it shows who has the last
task
no it doesn't okay just hit you i'm
pressing it nothing's happening
what okay guys husband and wife
okay you're right you're right you're
right you're right
there's a security camera that we can
eavesdrop on the conversation hey wait a
minute
hey
it wasn't me because i was with aaron
what the [ __ ]
no that doesn't work that way it was
probably a while ago yeah we don't know
when
it was killed oh my god i was very
suspicious of dan and you know now he's
dead
actually i wasn't suspicious of him at
all i think i know who both
are but i kind of just want you guys to
go for it you know have fun
just just [ __ ] around it's whatever
tasks are done
wait so who found the body a lot of
people a bunch of us saw it on the
camera reported it
classic skip on eight i we were all
together this whole time i don't know
what to do this is um this is crazy guys
this round
this is unheard of this is this is like
a real this is like how the game
should be just like i don't know
also i'm pretty sure ross is not doing
his tasks just to see if they can play
it out so
that would be really helpful for us
for us he said no in discord
no no no we can we just need to talk
this out which one of us has a motive
that's the real question who
would question yeah was it yeah strange
very strange maybe it was you go around
never no maybe okay well if we all just
stay here and then aaron shows up
getting susie
everyone's staying in the room guys i'm
just trying to watch a movie oh cool
yeah
if anyone can he doesn't get impostor
often let her just happen i'm just gonna
go check vitals real quick well i still
don't even know if it's her
let's just see we don't even know what's
happening i don't even know it's her
it didn't work don't even know that the
other one is right here with us either
yeah lights are off i can see the
projector way better now yeah this is
great
thank you it's just movie night now do
we just leave them off just like for for
fun
yeah yes yeah somebody
they're doing their tasks it's not us
it's wrong
nobody's dead nobody's dead well i mean
two people are dead but i didn't like
themselves yeah but they're not dead
well i'm i'm not emotionally compromised
about their death so i'm fine
if it's aaron and susie nah i've been
with aaron in the world
maybe that's true
taking care of business all by myself
oh man oh she got me every time right
never knew bro she killed me and then
ran back to the group like
oh my god okay oh that's crazy
what is happening i actually don't know
how that happens so weird i'm actually
very scared
oh how dare
chris hanson come on
i really don't know look i told him i'd
kill him he's dead
what more can i say guys i said thinking
about it
does that mean you're the killer no are
you sure
i think it's time for me to die i think
it's time for spedice to die
i think it's time for me to die oh the
spudaisey i get it
i don't know did i see uh he didn't do
this wow well he just said he did so
what are we doing
he says otherwise allowed he just
admitted guilt no yeah
he just doesn't care how is this i don't
think he's doing this i feel like
everyone
happened
what have we become oh my god
this is when you go so negative iq that
you loop back to 999.
yeah it's actually getting kind of smart
i'm honestly a little bit impressed yeah
because honestly who's the other one
it's susie and who susie killed me but
honestly like
she could be innocent i have no idea oh
whoa whoa attacker and susie
whoa hey i was right
no it was susie oh my god what the [ __ ]
i just want to see if they can pull it
off yeah yeah i i have one button to hit
on simon says i just
want to see what happens i mean if they
do it okay i realize now that i hit the
button and it totally looks like it's me
but i did not kill jayden oh my god okay
so then it had to be dodged
oh my god yes no i was definitely you
know i thought that was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me because i
know hacker and aaron went with us but
oh my god vote off susie i'm pretty sure
this is so evil my concern is now that
hacker has been playing me this whole
game and now i'm very scared yeah
i gave the game to the imposters i feel
like i was thinking about it that's okay
man
this is magic everybody's real scared oh
no
[Music]
so hard that he let his wife
may i say one thing to my my my co-host
aaron i i saw the little powwow you had
with susie where you said
babe is it you and she said yes and then
every time she murdered someone and you
immediately said
what is happening
[Music]
you